est-ce qu'on fait le soir on vient à la
lumière bienvenue à tampée on est
content on reste quand même donc si tu
veux pas prendre 500000 € par mois un
million par mois le système judo vous
dites
si tu veux pas faire ça sors de ce
système protège tes enfants je peux me
permettre je trouve que tu es aucune
légitimation à dire ça
existe pas si ça existe bien sûr que ça
existe ça existe
comme moi du Maroc à 2 ans
calme-toi Daniel mot calme-toi oui il y
a un très beau proverbe israélien qui
dit tout ce que la vie te donne sans
effort elle te le reprend et ces gens
c'est ça c'est cette génération c'est ça
c'est-à-dire que ils sont devenus
célèbres riches ils ont tout eu ils
n'ont rien fait aucun effort pour ça
rien et ce film et il travaille pas il y
a pas d'études il y a rien et la vie se
venge toujours effectivement elle te le
reprend et là maintenant on commence à
avoir toutes les sanctions des réseaux
sociaux et ça tombe et elle pleure et je
suis triste pour elle cette jeune fille
même quand elle pleure elle se met
encore en scène et on va dans le sens de
ce que tu dis pourquoi tout le monde ne
le fait pas à ce moment-là pas tout le
monde n'est pas millionnaire
milliardaire pourquoi tout le monde ne
le fait pas à ce moment-là tu sais si
simple c'est quoi la recette ouais je
défends personne je connais pas non plus
mais pourquoi
on rigole pas s'il te plaît Mathieu
pourquoi tout le monde ne fait pas ce
qu'elle fait pour être riche parce que
je pense que les enfants parce que
pardon déjà je vais être un petit peu
méchant mais je pense que sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est pas toujours les
gens qui ont
enfin on va dire que
quand le plus de de de de culture de de
d'éducation de machin de normalement si
tu étais éduqué un peu correctement on
t'apprend que tu fais des études tu as
ton bac tu fais des études tu travailles
un peu tu es un petit boulot tout ça et
puis tu avances et puis tu grimpes
finalement tes PARENTS tu dis ça et
t'aide à dire tout ça donc pour toi
c'est tous des pauvres gens ces gens-là
en fait c'est pas des dépenses je dis
juste normalement normalement moi si
j'avais des enfants si moi je vais te
dire un truc moi je pense moi je te le
dis et il y en a plein moi que je vois
qu'ils font des vidéos et tout je suis
désolé c'est un talent je suis désolé
c'est un talent il y a un talent non non
il y a un talent désolé elle a raison
sur un truc sinon tout le monde le
ferait et je vais te dire tout le monde
a envie d'être millionnaire
une communauté de gens quand elle dit ma
communauté
alors j'ai des followers
la communauté si je l'ai déjà dit c'est
des gens qui ont le talent qu'on se ces
jeunes femmes c'est mère de famille on
le talent que plein de gens se
reconnaissent en elle mais ça c'est un
talent mais si on la suit poupette et il
y a un c'est du rayoncé
et je voudrais juste répondre à Raymond
ok quand on a une notoriété sur les
réseaux ou ailleurs on est il y a un
revers de la médaille c'est la critique
ça parfait la critique y compris
agressive mais Raymond pas les menaces
pas le harcèlement là on va au-delà
c'est-à-dire que tu fais alors le mec tu
peux pas légitimer les menaces
avec mention ça vient de me le dire
mais j'ai pas dit qu'elle était idiotes
de culture
mais j'ai pas dit l'été idiote pas du
tout je dis juste aux gens voilà dans la
vie moi je l'ai vécu à la Bourse avant
j'étais trader dans les bourses voilà et
j'ai vu que tu avais eu il y a eu la
bulle comme ça autour des télécoms à
l'époque et tout d'un coup tout a
explosé les gens gagnent de l'argent
très rapidement tout ce qui se fait
rapidement comme ça sans effort cette
pète à la gueule un jour même au Rambo
bonjour
il y a un départ
il y a un départ comment comment est-ce
que ces personnes commencent il y a un
départ c'est pas question
et comment elles ont commencé et après
ça devient un engrenage non c'est un
engrenage on peut plus sortir de leur
grenade après c'est fini tu vas faire
quoi tu vas arrêter tu gagnes tu gagnes
des millions d'euros c'est je vais je
vais vous dire le problème c'est qu'il
est en train de vie derrière c'est que
les mecs qui peuvent paraître quand ils
ont envoyé quand tu as rouler en 4x4
Bentley tu as pas envie de reprendre ta
Clio le lendemain
contre la Suisse il se fait insulté il
se fait insulter tous les noms
alors il a continué si tu veux continuer
tu assumes si tu veux pas continuer à
faire un baptême est dégueulasse mais
dégueulasse
Bentley mais en même temps elle veut pas
pleurer elle veut pas d'ennuis bah soit
tu prends ta belle tête et les enduits
soit tu vas le métier ou tu roules en
même temps tu te fais cracher dessus